yeah we're doing this let's just get it
over with Disney's Marvel Spider-Man
2017 has the worst title for a
Spider-Man cartoon ever because it's so
hard to distinguish which one you're
talking about without just putting the
year on it it's a show with no intro
it's a show where the Green Goblin looks
like this it's a show that's so
unbothered by any sense of continuity
that it simultaneously exists in the
same universe as the rest of these
Marvel shows and Ultimate Spider-Man
somehow we'll get into that it's weird
and it's a show that is pretty
universally hated by people on the
internet for merely existing I've been
pretty neutral about it over the years
because I simply hadn't watched more
than one episode of it I saw it was
unimpressed and then didn't check back
on it for like 6 years but since I've
reviewed every other Spidey cartoon I
feel obligated to finally talk about it
because I hate to leave the job 90%
finished and then quit so these are my
thoughts as someone who didn't watch
this show as it was coming out but found
it years after it was already finished
and over with did it deserve the hate is
it really that bad stick around and find
out but first a word from our sponsor
Dungeon Hunter 6 Dungeon Hunter 6 the
newest installment in the classic hack
and/ franchise is a free-to-play aprg
with a unique hero collector feature
play as a bounty hunter with multiple
class options and not only slay bosses
but also recruit them as your posy it
features both PVE and PVP game modes
including real-time Guild Wars and Guild
raids for multiplayer play in Dungeon
Hunter 6 killing a boss is not the end
for every boss you defeat you can summon
up to three of them in the battlefield
is your squad to use their skills or
even shape shift into them to harness
their powers yourself with over a 100
uniquely designed bosses to beat and
collect and new classes and units
updated monthly the fun of utilizing
them in battle is endless Dungeon Hunter
also lets you get creative with how you
play ever wanted to play as a cat during
a stealth mission of course you have
everyone has you can also customize
mounts and ride various fantasy
creatures in battle when meeting other
other players and Dungeon Hunter 6
Graphics are out of this world on mobile
with stunning skill animations optimized
for multicasting ensuring the best
visual experience and smooth as combat
on mobile devices download the game now
for free on both Android and iOS and use
my link in the description or scan the
QR code if you're on PC get a special
starter pack worth $50 using my link
with 10 summoning Scrolls one SSR
Lieutenant demonic wolf and one
accessory pack use your game account to
enter the launch lucky spin event for
free to win great prizes like an iPhone
15 Pro Max PS5 and more check the
description out for more details see you
there now back to the
[Music]
video after Ultimate Spider-Man broke
100 episodes and started to slow down
because of waning interest and possibly
a DUI from the lead actor Disney quickly
shoved this show into production to air
within a year of ultimate's cancellation
at first the marketing material and
concept art made it really seem like
this would be a cool new look for Spidey
it had that MCU influence which was
understandable with homecoming releasing
that same year but it also had such
vibrant colors and such a cool look then
the show came out and looked nothing
like that instead of using the Ultimate
Comics as inspiration for some of its
character designs and stories this
series looked to the recent at the time
Mainline Comics to include new additions
to Spidey lore like Max Modell a school
that was based on Horizon lab an arc
based on spider Island and Superior
Spider-Man and the addition of Miles
Morales to give him an amazing friend
rather than a team of mean-spirited
[__] that he liked for no reason it
didn't quite have the same limitations
as ultimate did with what it could and
couldn't do we were finally allowed to
have more classic Spidey stuff too like
a proper black suit Spider-Man to Eddie
Brock Venom pipeline or a tech based
Green Goblin but the execution of all of
these things was lacking and left fans
old and young pretty cold on this show
it made it to more episodes than
spectacular but it still didn't have the
staying power that ultimate did now
everyone dunks on this show is the black
sheep of Spidey cartoons considering
it's the weakest in a pretty strong
lineage dating back to the 1960s firstly
now that it's over the sense of hatred
is harder to obtain because it's come
and gone I wasn't actively following it
and being perplexed by its weirder
choices like I was with Ultimate
Spider-Man I just heard bits and pieces
or saw my friends posting Clips to laugh
out on Twitter early on I must admit the
first 10 episodes are the worst slog but
once you get through that it becomes a
lot more watchable I can't tell if the
show started to find its footing once
miles joined up or if I just became
desensitized to its weirdness but it
stopped being painful to watch the very
least his shoulders haven't been
tampered with take points off for that
belt though a the season 3 costume never
mind and those gloves yeah it's
animation is obviously extremely low
budget for a show like this Everyone
likes to talk about the lack of shading
the basic and undetailed backgrounds but
for me the biggest offender on the
visual front is the color pallet I've
never seen a show this aggressively dull
looking except for the Guardians of the
Galaxy cartoon that this crossed over
with look at this scene during the
daytime why but that had more detailed
backgrounds spectacular Spider-Man's
colors tended to get very muddy and
brown but this is a whole new level it's
so gray and unexciting to look at at
least Ultimate Spider-Man for all its
faults in writing had strong animation
and pretty decent fight scenes it had
great character designs in a clear art
direction that didn't feel limited by
money it had the sauce visually these
character designs are so blocky and low
effort it's trying to use the MCU
aesthetic of panel lines and layers of
fabric but with no shading or variation
in colors it's just random lines on a
completely flatl looking costume captain
Captain America looks so naked without
the letter that stands for France let's
play Greg L's least favorite game name
that face without hearing their voice or
seeing their outfit you need to be able
to identify these characters by name in
under 10
seconds and one for the
ladies
couldn't play this game with Spectacular
Spider-Man that's for sure on the
exceedingly rare occasion that the
backgrounds have some texture and the
characters have some lighting applied to
them doesn't look too bad kind of
reminds me of the new Superman show but
those situations don't happen nearly
often enough to break up the monotony
I'll give it credit for some
occasionally decent animation on the
fight choreography but the biggest
hurdle of getting into the series above
all others was the visuals being so
plain Lan and Bland the second biggest
hurdle is the dialogue so that just
happened I think the overall plots are
actually fine sometimes even outright
good but these are conveyed with really
shoddy scripts this is a Spider-Man that
says according to my calculations and
carry the one out loud in conversations
to sound more smart if I want to propel
it out of Harm's Way against an average
wind speed of 12 mph the trajectory
should be little busy at the moment
carry the
got okay I understand the scientist
aspect of Spider-Man can get
underutilized by certain adaptations but
this is the clumsiest and most blunt way
to handle it he has to remind you with
the most awkward techno Babble every
chance that he can get to the point he
sounds like a bad fanfiction version of
Donatello from Ninja Turtles instead of
Spider-Man even the great power great
responsibility dialogue is presented
like a chemistry formula and it just
feels a bit forced
but I also kind of appreciate the
sincerity they come at it with the
science jargon slows down around season
2 but never quite goes away both
Marvel's and Ultimate Spider-Man break
my cardinal rule of writing Spider-Man
quip dialogue Spider-Man should be
annoying and unfunny to the bad guys not
the audience I've noticed a lot of
writers fail at writing these quips by
resorting to Spidey rambling a sort of
meta self-examination of the quips and
saying [__] like wow I just said had a
cat pun and you're a cat or that joke
sounded better in my head LMAO that's
impossible it's not impossible it's
cat uh cat can't think of a good cat pun
right now I was positive I'd run into
you someday I just made that one up
science jokes are hilarious don't you
think I can't think of anything
[Music]
quippy Oh I thought of a quit ah too
late now why would you want this Mr Pur
snatcher it seriously doesn't match your
look banter that's something Spider-Man
taught me and once he starts referencing
the fact that he's making jokes they
stop being jokes and are just
discussions about jokes once Spider-Man
has verbally said H get it you have
failed to write his quips and need to
start over
completely looks like I have to clip
your
wi get it it's a bird joke so this is
your secret slide out get it I can come
up with names like that all day this
place is a hive of criminal science get
it Hive oh oh no one's ever around for
the good ones you got to stop asking
people if they get things but then how
do I know if they got it they'll laugh
if you explain something humorous it's
not humorous but Xavier these shows are
for children and it could probably make
an 8-year-old laugh yeah I'd make an
8-year-old laugh if I shoved your head
into an elephant's ass and duct taped
around your neck to cre a vacuum seal
shut the hell up symmetrical double
trunk human centiant is this bit too
Juvenile and unfunny for you well the
target audience for that joke is the 8
to2 demographic and I wrote it to sell
toys so it's above all criticism do you
hear how you sound being for kids is not
an excuse for things to be
[Music]
lazy let's address this since it was the
most common response when I was talking
about ultimate Spider-Man and it applies
here too it would move me to tears if I
still had tears to
shed just because it's aimed at kids
doesn't mean it needs to be mindless
unfunny noise that treats the audience
like they're stupid the best media for
kids is the stuff that treats them with
dignity and respects them enough to know
that they can handle more mature themes
if it's presented in the right way and
tries to open their minds to the worlds
around them you can have children's
media with deep likable characters
character arcs with growth and
development well-written comedy mature
Concepts when you're homeless people
look right through you it's like you're
not even there yeah I've been guilty of
that unique art design complex stories
you're going to kill me so that Superman
can't the Justice League's reputation
Will Survive my actions and Superman's
Legacy will remain intact interesting
plan moral dilemmas important life
lessons and real World issues that are
happening right outside your window the
plague has people frightened they're
looking for someone to blame we're an
easy target only scientific inquiry can
overcome the hysteria that's gripping
the
country or at the very least interesting
and wellth thought Out World building
and creative settings it's the best
feeling when you can return to that same
media as an adult and still find it
enjoyable or even appreciate it from a
totally New Perspective now that you're
older and viewing it from a different
lens than you did as a child
as a kid I used to watch you with my
father the Great Ghost was my hero so it
wasn't all for
nothing you're reexperiencing it as a
whole new person now so it's like
learning to love it all over again for
the qualities it had that made it
Timeless the blink of an
eye in the end what matters isn't how
long we've lived but how fully we've
lived the good we've done the friends
we've made
the love we shared along the
way until we meet again old
friend not every show needs to be like
that bro what you mean good well no but
I expect them to at least try and you
know the MCU and Star Wars are meant for
children but we talk about those with
deadly levels of importance because
they're liveaction instead of animated
storytelling isn't given a free pass to
be low effort depending on its target
audience I hope these more recent shows
to much higher standards than the older
ones because a precedent has been set
that these shows can and should be
better if you know these series can have
all these things then why shouldn't they
you're settling for Less kids aren't
stupid and have no standards they
deserve good shows too you can't just
wave off any legitimate criticism with
that plus I was 13 when Ultimate
Spider-Man came out I was in the Target
demographic it's not like I'm a
40-year-old man talking about why Blues
Clues is a poorly written mystery plot
that being said this series doesn't piss
me off nearly as bad but it also gets
none of the same lame excuses and
apologists as the one it replaced it's
so hated across the board probably
because it's not quite old enough yet to
be considered nostalgic for the people
who think every single piece of media
they consumed when they were 5 years old
as a masterpiece once everyone who
watched this show as a toddler turns
like 16 we're going to see a major
switch up and a strong insistence that
it was secretly underrated in the best
Spidey show of all time Ultimate
Spider-Man feels like 104 episodes of
someone smugly jingling keys in your
face expecting you to laugh and clap
your hands Marvel Spider-Man is at the
very least trying it's not really
succeeding but I feel more sincerity
from this show I don't feel like I'm
being talked down to by this one real
talk though miles has all the best jokes
in the show no one's coming after
me new spider I have C for
you looks like that Spider by G great
comic timing oh I can't I have a date
later a date you kidding I'm never doing
anything unlike its predecessor this
show has a great voice cast going for it
we got the same mil is the PS4 game so
he sounds good I like the tradition of
having previous Spidey voice actors
playing a villain in the new show oh
come on nothing really do you know how
long it took to perfect that entrance
shans ship's a dying art form
and Josh Keaton's Norman Osborne works
surprisingly well I am the general of
this Battalion Otto not you you are a
mere doctor and take orders from me now
get my son to safety we also have
alltime greats on the cast like Jason
spiss Fred tatore Greg Griffin Ben disin
my boy Yuri John demaggio and you know
what you're all wrong about Robbie Damon
I'm putting my foot down Robbie Damon is
a great Spidey voice I know it seems
like he's done some bad stuff but people
thought that about me too it's not about
what other people have said about me
it's about what I do all I'm saying is
that I saw proof that he's not a
complete bad guy that was enough for me
though my evidence for this is the
Marvel anime disc Wars and future
Avengers he was fantastic in both of
those yes his performance isn't Stellar
in this show but not many others are
either even though they're all great vas
this show just chooses the strangest
takes to use I think it came down to
messy Voice Direction because I know
these guys are better than this in other
shows and games but often deliver flat
sounding performances in this series in
particular if Jim Cummings isn't blowing
you away then has to be the direction
even still this is a really strong cast
for these characters so I'd never say
the voice acting was a big drawback on
this show even if they do sound a little
weird at
times the Jackal is Professor Raymond
Warren they changed jackal's first name
in this CU this is the first thing he
and Miles Morales have been in at the
same time props for this being the only
Spidey cartoon to use slide that's
appreciated all right I've heard it
before but it was a massive shock to
just see how weird and unsatisfying the
choices for the villains were yes a
considerable percentage of Spider-Man
villains are mad scientists like almost
all of them but they're not also the
same ages him so much of the show
revolves around Horizon High and
multiple other gifted science schools
that every major character is a student
or a teacher at one of these and this
has a really unfortunate effect of
making Peter feel spectacularly
unspecial in his own show while you're
at it Crush The Wristband of Herman's
Gauntlet that's where he houses the
power source thanks vas every character
is a vunderkind I took the revised
designs you emailed me realigned the
coils and look every 15-year-old is a
scientific genius I've been working on a
retinal identification app and not
unique ways where they all have specific
fields of science they excel in I want
you to meet the newer cortex's new home
I call it the living brain may I
interest you in a beverage everyone
seems exactly as smart as everyone else
in any given scenario I've isolated the
mutation in your bloodstream so Rhino
Miles Morales Gwen Stacy and Yak
corazone are all students at Horizon
High the Venom symbiote is being studied
for a student project at the school s F
man has a teenage scientist daughter
that copied his powers together with his
money and my knowledge of science we
found a way to charge my particle so
that I could live I'll be a better stand
person Electro is a teenage scientist
that built a super suit the sweet sweet
Bounty cash I'm going to get from
turning you in is going to fund the
completion of this awesome electr suit I
invented hobie's Teenage brother a young
scientist built his Prowler gear it's my
brother the one who designs all my tech
at least we got Hobie as Prowler one
last time before no adaptation ever does
that again maybe in spiderverse 3 he'll
like become the new Prowler and give up
on being Spider-Man is like a wink and
Nod thing I don't know I don't think so
Dr Connor works at Horizon Doc O is a
19-year-old teacher at Horizon High
Jackal Spencer SMI and vulture are
teachers at Norman Osborne's rival
Science school where Harry Osborne
attends after getting kicked out of
horizon Harry builds all of the goblin
Tech himself steal spider and John
Jameson are students at the Osborne
Academy these science schools are so
Central in all the plots that Horizon
decides to make Spider-Man their
official mascot because he's basically
always on the campus stopping some
runamu experiment or another he's not so
much New York superhero in this show as
he is just Horizon High superhero
there's enough spare gear down here I
think I could rig up some gamma
detectors help me find components I've
recreated The Cure using the synth blood
and what was left of my serum now we can
Mass produce it without any fear of side
effects the main frame is working to
isolate any foreign enzymes in Alexis's
blood I'll check the DNA
sequencing send me those figures this
genetic strain will require its own
anti- diffuser check out the security
robot I made yo something isn't right
looks like I get to show off my new
Scrambler it can cut the power to
anything mechanical and so every
character in the Side cast can whip up a
chemical formula or a special machine
and no time at all to help Spidey beat
the villains in fact a lot of the time
they end up just doing that stuff for
him while he's floundering around
helplessly and can't beat the villain on
his own Spider-Man hang
on wa love that piece of tech thanks
stand back Spider-man we used parts of
the carnival games to create a
coagulation gun Peter is constantly
being in your face about how much he
loves science yet is somehow the least
useful scientist in the show but that
creates a problem where you know when
every character has the same expertise
the same level of intelligence and the
same career desires a lot of them feel
like pretty much the same character
nothing really distinguishes miles from
Gwen or either of them from Peter or Ana
I guess Anna is like just more angry and
this is only worsened when all three of
them get the same Powers as Peter so
Peter isn't special for being a science
genius and he's definitely not special
for being a SP spy superhero guy
away miles where are
you miles
mil yes Spiderman he's sedated stop
shouting his name you dumb
[__] 10 episodes in and Miles becomes
the second Spider-Man this show cuts out
the middleman and has miles Gwen and Ana
get powers likely within a year of Peter
so really the only thing he has over
them is a few additional months of
experience but they catch up to him so
quickly that him being the first spider
person doesn't matter soon enough they
never really give miles a superhero name
either which is irritating what I'm not
Spider-Man I'm a totally different guy
it's just Spider-Man and the guy who is
here too and that's
just that's just giving more fuel to the
most annoying [__] people on the
internet the Disney plus subtitles call
him kidnet and spy d
but neither of those are said in the
show itself the mentor and protege
Dynamic just can't work in this world so
they don't even bother with it we're all
equals except miles and any other spider
friends won't show up for multiple
episodes in a row so Peter can still
have solo Adventures which just kind of
begs the question some of the time why
aren't they helping this show manages to
also get Spider Girl and Spider Gwen in
there by having them be two of the
millions of New Yorkers to get copies of
Peter's powers in the form of a virus
during the spider Island are Gwen runs
around without a mask and spider Gwen is
just a name she gets from fans after
being seen rolling with Spidey on the
news I'm not so sure why she became so
noteworthy considering a few hours after
that everyone else got the same Powers
but they were trying to work in spider
Gwen as a reasonable in universe name I
feel like this character will never have
the same upward momentum as miles simply
because they can't come up with a
satisfying name for her she's always
going to be associated with a completely
different character that's been famously
dead for half a century they still
eventually steal ghost spider's name for
her though which seems frivolous since
she was just wearing the same costume
and puts on a mask now like people know
it's you you can't walk it
back I don't know it just I don't think
the writers even really thought about it
or cared about it I really wish it could
just be Peter and Miles Ana is the third
one at the most would be okay but four
spider people is really pushing it at
the very at least it's not as intrusive
as the spider team in Ultimate they
don't overstay their welcome by being in
every single episode after the initial
awkward Meandering of the first 10
episodes the show starts to find its
groove of storylines it's got a bit of
that traditional bad guy of the week
stuff in there but it's also got really
lengthy serialized stories adapting
recent comic arcs from Dan slot's run on
the character spider island arc is kind
of fun I don't know I liked it I like
seeing New Yorkers paying tribute to
Spidey and helping him out and it was a
fun excuse to get some no costume brawls
for Peter since he could just pretend to
be infected like everyone else it was
always cool seeing him in the Ultimate
Comics getting caught up in a fight at a
time where he couldn't put his costume
on so you just see this tiny 15-year-old
using his Herculean strength to smash
giant monsters half to death and this is
the only animated series to throw a bit
of that in there at the very least this
show has a marginally better Venom than
the Ultimate Spider-Man show did and
does a legitimate attempt at Eddie's
rivalry with Peter at the bugle no Harry
Venom thank God though Eddie's not a
particularly fleshed out character
before getting the suit it all happens
pretty fast and much like the comics his
motivation for hating Peter is murky and
works better if you just assume the
Symbiote is the driving force behind it
nobody's doing it like 90s Spider-Man I
don't know what I'm going to do Anna I
had no idea it was so
expensive the tuition bill I knew it and
job
listings no a may this stops here here I
won't let you take an extra job just so
that I can stay at Horizon this is
unfortunately the worst version of this
scene but it's still good that they
included it I like how Peter gets a job
at the bugle because he can't keep
paying his tuition Horizon classes start
Monday and if I can't get Spidey footage
to sell to the Daily Bugle I can't
afford tuition this is uncomfortable but
I'm sure you know why I called you here
I'll have my tuition money in soon I
promise I just need a couple more days
unfortunately I don't know how long I
can keep your spot open here if we don't
get a payment
it's something brought up in multiple
episodes until he reluctantly settles on
selling unflattering videos of
Spider-Man getting his butt handed to
him so he can stay at the school but
this Arc ends when Eddie loses the suit
and doesn't come back for the rest of
the show which is a giant bummer they
dedicated so much time to Doc O and
Harry Osborne but Eddie gets shafted so
quickly and it just feels like a giant
missed opportunity especially since the
last season is so Venom Centric it just
feels weird that Eddie is not there at
all or even really talked about the show
is doing that thing where Venom is the
suit and not the combination of it and
someone else so the host becomes
irrelevant as the series goes on Venom
is just the goo doesn't matter who's
inside I guess which I don't like
there's also a 13 episode long Arc about
Peter being overwhelmed with so many
super villains and his homework that he
doesn't sleep at all and is just
completely exhausted by the end and that
leads into six more episodes of a
superior Spider-Man adaptation that's
actually not that
bad help
Spider-Man
help just passed him by no way he did
that unlike the comic it didn't overstay
its welcome and it didn't last too long
and it didn't rely on all of Peter's
closest friends being totally oblivious
idiots the whole Arc is about miles
knowing it's not Peter right away and
trying to restore the original spidey's
mind he's the one who gets the Avengers
to run tests on auto and and just won't
let it go he's basically the one that
gets Peter in position to return to his
body though it still gives Otto that
moment of self-sacrifice realizing he's
not Spider-Man I wish the comics had
miles and Peter this tight they only
talk to each other like once a year in
passing which sucks I might actually
like this version of superior better
than the book just because the way
Brooklyn Spidey is utilized as such a
key figure that's fun and cool I like
when he's important then we get the
rather disappointing goblin war Arc with
no well no goblin not the correct one
the weirdest part of this show is that
Norman Osborne never officially becomes
Green Goblin Harry becomes hobgoblin and
serves as a recurring Ally for Spidey
Norman steals his suit one time and then
fake dies then later becomes a symbiote
infused dark Goblin because Dan slot
story lines the Green Goblin in this
show is actually the vulture
which which is what whatever don't care
for it but it does end on a very nice
Redemption Arc for Doc O that ties the
whole season together in a nice bow I
thought it was kind of ballsy to
actually just kill him off and they
commit to it he's gone season 3 is cut
short at 12 episodes which just screams
that this show was canceled abruptly but
they do throw in a time- tested classic
invasion of the Symbiote storyline I
like that they use the gwam design feels
like a missed opportunity to not have
Harry's hobgoblin suit styled like demo
Goblin though oh and they got JM dematas
on some of it de de de de Deus no wonder
this episode has a better script than
all the others it's like the only time
May has some character development in
the whole show and Spidey isn't
constantly being cringy and a moonnight
crossover on top of it very Web of
Shadows I dig that they also toss in a
few symbiote characters that never
really show up in adaptations like
scream Mania and Scorn though they're
just space monsters for the purposes of
the plot which is a little disappointing
the final episode uses a bit of
inspiration from Donnie Kate's Venom too
but not nearly as developed this show
has a real problem of throwing
characters in there for the sake of just
saying they had them but not developing
them at all or having them actually act
like themselves just hey we got Mania
kind of not Andy Benton just like the
idea of mania she's like Sonic but a
symbiote cuz you know her [__] head
can only exist in a 2d drawing and it
would look weird in 3D there's a better
overall attempt here at actual Peter
Parker personal life Centric storylines
than ultimate he can't pay for school
and he has money problems his personal
relationships are suffering as a result
of superhero stuff you know that good
stuff but both shows are burdened by the
recent problem with Spidey media they
don't know how to write a cast of
characters without giving them all
superpowers to keep them relevant I
think if they could get away with it
Marvel would give Aunt May superpowers
and throw her in a costume so they don't
need to write things like oh she's
dealing with the health issues that one
faces in the Twilight years of their
life and the financial difficulties
resulting from such or oh she's
depressed because her husband died in a
home invasion they'd rather just put her
in a big stupid robot suit and have her
punching people I mean [__] Mary Jane is
like Ben 10 in the comics right now even
Liz Allen in this show is screw ball a
young red-haired YouTuber who can't get
people to watch her show and unless she
centers the videos on Spider-Man all the
damn time I appreciate the relatability
of that you'll never be her though
there's also the weird matter of this
Show's placement in a shared Marvel
animated Marvel universe so Ultimate
Spider-Man and Avengers Assemble both
had a backdoor pilot for Guardians of
the Galaxy but their voices and designs
in their final show looked a lot more
like the movie counterparts once it
started in 2015 fair enough we can
excuse the change but then it ran
alongside ultimate and Avengers assemble
Avengers Assemble had multiple guest
appearances by Ultimate Spider-Man and
those versions of them appear in his
show okay not for nothing but I come
from a team of Heroes and Nova who are
all teenagers so I know a thing or three
about infighting he's doing cutaways
talking about working for shield and
does the oh so hilarious monkey sound
effect that's him that's Ultimate
Spider-Man a connection is established
the Spider-Man of this universe is the
Drake Bell one but but then Avengers
Assemble has a season 5 episode where
Robbie Damon Spidey shows up instead
then the Guardians of the Galaxy series
crosses over with his show so somehow
both Spider-Man and both Guardians are
cannoned to Avengers Assemble at the
same time what was going on over there
that's like if Andrew Garfield showed up
in the first Avengers as planned then we
didn't see him for four years then Civil
War happened with Tom Holland and all
the Avengers just pretended to not
notice the only answer I've really been
given for how this works is that season
five of Avengers Assemble just takes
place in Another Universe from the first
four seasons which is stupid and also
season one of Avengers Assemble has
flashbacks to Earth Mightiest Heroes and
that's supposed to be in the universe
with Spectacular Spider-Man so it's just
a disaster the only host for Carnage in
this universe is Thanos oddly enough for
the Guardians of the Galaxy episode
Peter's rendered in an art style closer
to Ultimate Spider-Man so he's more tall
and muscular it's just weird seeing this
design look so much more manly his
costume The Mask especially looks almost
exactly like Ultimate Spider-Man just
with sleeves and a segmented belt they
also use the comic black suit in venom
design instead of the ones from this
series but Max Modell shows up and he's
completely on modeled the main shows art
style there's a really strange lack of
cohesive art design and continuity
around all of these shows just wasn't as
tightly planned as the 9s Mau the dcau
the yast verse or or even the actual MCU
movies which show was Canon to which
which designs were used it was all over
the place they didn't really care maybe
they just didn't think it mattered and I
guess it doesn't if we're being honest
but that shared Universe stuff can be
really fun to engage with when it's
handled well and it's odd to see an
attempt at one that's so halfhazard done
especially under Marvel's
Banner no
a weird thing about doing Peter's origin
in a heavily pre-established Marvel
Universe instead of early on is that
he's now in the same age bracket as all
of the Legacy characters that ended up
in the Champions like iron har amadas
Hulk and Miss Marvel there's even a
vague hint at him having a crush on Miss
Marvel and I guess I wouldn't be totally
opposed to these versions of the
characters dating but given the age
difference between their comic
counterparts I see why it wasn't pursued
unlike no bitch's MC Vagina repellent
over here and shockingly every other
Spidey cartoon this guy actually ends up
with Mary Jane at the end no
Cliffhangers or abandoned story lines or
nothing good for you dork oh wait they
never resolved the fact that miles's Dad
off screen was transformed into a
sentient swarm of bees bent on murdering
his son oh well when I started watching
Ultimate Spider-Man I went into it
wanting to like it and defend it but
ended up not enjoying major portions of
it
this show is the opposite I went in
expecting to hate it and found that it
wasn't as unpleasant a marathon as I
prepared for but my overall opinion of
both shows in the end despite their
shortcomings is the same which
is eh it's fine it's watchable I mostly
didn't want to kill myself by the end of
it well not because of the show anyway
neither of them are as good as the shows
preceding them even at its worst I can't
hate this show there's plenty of things
wrong with it and I absolutely see why
people don't Vibe with it I certainly
don't love it or anything it doesn't get
a rise out of me at all it's just like
fine most of the time when stuff about
it sucks it's thankfully kind of
inoffensive I guess I think I'm just so
detached from it compared to Ultimate
Spider-Man where I was watching that one
in bits and pieces as it came out and
didn't like it as a kid and can still be
kind of harsh on it now but seeing this
show for the first time over the course
of like the last month before this video
drops it's hard for me to feel strongly
about it either way maybe it's just cuz
I'm looking at it with the eyes of an
adult instead of a kid this time it's
not an underrated overlooked Hidden Gem
but it's not a complete flaming disaster
that makes me angry whenever I think
about it that's reserved for Pacific Rim
Uprising the worst movie ever made by
humans Marvel Spider-Man has a lot going
against it but I think in spite of it
all it's
perfectly serviceable it just doesn't
excel at anything it's just another
Spider-Man show relatively unspecial and
not as significant as its peers but then
I guess it goes to a school for really
gifted Spidey shows it's hard to stand
out when the competition is that
Fierce I always get mad at YouTube for
not putting my videos in the
subscription box because people will
comment finally Xavier uploads again
after all these years not knowing three
other videos came out within the last
month already so maybe that stupid Bell
icon thing will help you remember I
exist if you want other ways to support
the channel you can always go hit up
that patreon for early videos and
exclusive stuff because it's just a
dollar I'm not kidding it's only $1
Isn't that cool if everyone who watched
this video donated $1 a month I'd be
able to afford a house for myself so
that would be that would be really cool
you can also check out our merch on tuu
or just buy some of my random stuff on
eBay I have a pretty substantial
collection of old toys that are still in
the box in perfect condition so go take
a look in case you find something you
like and like lastly since this is a
YouTube video and you probably play
fortnite drop my Creator code Xavier GM
next time you buy a silly dance or a
cool character skin really helps me out
see you next
[Music]
time